como no se observa que la reacción de
deshidratación ocurra a 298 kelvin el
estudiante afirma que la reacción tiene
una constante de equilibrio menor a 1.00
a 298 kelvin los datos termodinámicos de
la reacción sustentan la afirmación del
estudiante justifica tu respuesta
incluyendo el cálculo del cambio de
energía libre de chips a 298 kelvin para
la reacción
ok primero veamos cuál es la afirmación
del estudiante como no se observa qué
ocurre a la reacción a 298 kelvin el
estudiante afirma que la reacción tiene
una constante de equilibrio menor a 1.00
a 298 kelvin eso es lo que afirma bueno
si estas ideas de la constante de
equilibrio o de la energía libre de
jeeps son completamente extrañas para
ustedes los invito a que vean los vídeos
en khan academy que hablan
sobre la energía libre de jeeps y las
constantes de equilibrio pero si esto ya
lo conocen tal vez me digan bueno pero
no conozco todas las fórmulas para que
conecten la información que nos dan en
el problema que me sirvan para calcular
delta g y después pasar de delta g a las
constantes de equilibrio y saber si la
constante de equilibrio es mayor o menor
a 1 o incluso igual a 1 pero no se
preocupen en la primera página de la
sección de respuestas libres nos han
dado todas las fórmulas que necesitamos
así que sólo tenemos que entender cuáles
podemos aplicar y qué es lo que podemos
hacer con esas ecuaciones entonces
primero pensemos en cómo podemos
calcular delta g con la información que
nos han dado si buscamos en la primera
página una de las fórmulas que nos
dieron tal vez recuerden cómo saber si
una reacción es espontánea o no y cómo
calcular delta g usando la temperatura
el cambio de entropía y el cambio de
entropía bueno aquí tenemos esta
la que literalmente copie y pegue de lo
que nos dan en el examen entonces aquí
tenemos el cambio de entropía para la
reacción la temperatura que es de 298
kelvin este es el cambio de entropía de
la reacción este es el cambio de
entropía estándar y este es el cambio de
entropía estándar entonces usando esto
podemos conocer el valor de delta g y
después podemos decir ok es consistente
es mayor a 0 la reacción es no
espontánea como se ha observado y bueno
después de calcular eso como podríamos
pasar de delta g a la constante de
equilibrio bueno también nos dicen que
delta g es igual a esto y eso conecta
delta g con la constante de equilibrio y
ya sabemos algunas cosas sobre r y t
de hecho conocemos exactamente sus
valores en caso de que las necesitemos
entonces empezamos aplicando estas
ecuaciones
primero escribiré la información que
tenemos cuál es el cambio de entropía
estándar y también cuál es el cambio de
entropía estándar también necesitamos la
temperatura que ya sabemos que es igual
a 298 kelvin y
más tarde nos preocupamos por r si es
que la necesitamos ok entonces aquí
arriba cuando nos dieron la reacción nos
dieron el cambio de entropía estándar y
el cambio de entropía estándar a 298
kelvin lo cual está perfecto entonces el
cambio de entropía estándar es de 45.5
kilo yo les por mol y el cambio de
entropía estándar es de 126 georges por
kelvin mol y miren esto es muy
interesante porque esto no los dan en
kilo georges pero esto no los dan en
yours así que primero debemos
asegurarnos de que nuestras unidades
sean consistentes
pasemos todo a jules entonces tenemos
que este valor es igual a 45 mil 500
soles por cada mol
vamos a describirlo abajo acuérdense
este es 45 45.500 y este es 126 jules
porque el vino entonces vamos a ver esto
es igual a 45 mil quinientos jules por
mol y esto es igual a 126 jules por
kelvin mol ok
así ya podemos calcular el valor de
delta g
entonces delta que estándar es igual a
el cambio de entropía estándar que es
igual a 45.500 jules por mol
- nuestra temperatura que es de 298
kelvin
por el cambio de entropía estándar que
es de 126 jules por kelvin mol entonces
como kelvin y kelvin se cancelan las
unidades que nos quedan aquí serán jules
por mol y aquí las unidades también son
yours formol así que simplemente podemos
calcular la diferencia usemos la
calculadora vamos a ver primero
multipliquemos esto tenemos 298 por 126
eso nos da ese valor y vamos a restarlo
a 45 mil 500 entonces simplemente lo
haré negativo y le sumamos 45 mil 500 y
eso es igual a 7 mil 952 y si queremos
mantenernos consistentes con las cifras
significativas que estamos usando si
queremos tres cifras significativas aquí
podemos escribir que es igual a 7.900
bueno aproximadamente igual a 7.950
entonces nuestra del taj estándar es
aproximadamente igual a 7.950 jules
formol y miren el hecho de que esto sea
mayor a 0 nos está diciendo que esto no
será espontáneo a esta temperatura lo
cual está coincidiendo con las
observaciones y esta es una muy buena
forma de comprobar entonces delta g es
mayor a 0 es consistente es consistente
con la reacción
al no ser
espontánea
espontánea al no ser espontánea a 298
kelvin
en los vídeos en can academy sobre la
energía libre de jeeps vemos con más
detalle todo esto pero una forma de
verlo es que esta es la energía el
cambio de energía disponible para
realizar un trabajo entonces si tenemos
más energía si la energía libre de jeeps
aumenta durante el transcurso de la
reacción eso significa que los productos
tienen más energía para realizar un
trabajo y eso significa que tenemos que
usar ese trabajo para que la reacción
pueda continuar ahora si delta g fuera
negativa eso significaría que los
productos tienen menos energía que los
reactivos para realizar un trabajo lo
que significa que se puede liberar esa
energía se puede realizar un trabajo y
la reacción es espontánea entonces como
en este caso es mayor a cero es una
reacción no espontánea pero eso no
responde la pregunta que nos han hecho
nosotros queremos comprobar la
afirmación de que la reacción tiene una
constante de
menor a 1 298 kelvin y para eso
afortunadamente también nos dieron la
fórmula que vincule a nuestra delta g
con la constante de equilibrio y miren
ya conocemos todo esto conocemos cr y
conocemos t aunque tal vez no tengamos
que usarlos porque no nos están pidiendo
que calculemos la constante de
equilibrio sólo nos están pidiendo que
comprobemos si es menor a 1
entonces si tomamos los 7.950 tours por
mol esto es igual a menos
rt rt
por el logaritmo natural de la constante
de equilibrio y ahora vamos a despejar
la constante de equilibrio si dividimos
ambos lados
entre menos r t menos rt nos queda que
el logaritmo natural de la constante de
equilibrio es igual a 7.950 jules por
mol entre menos rt o también lo
podríamos decir como y para quitar el
logaritmo natural e elevado a la menos
7.950 jules por mol entre rt es igual
acá y podríamos calcular esto porque
sabemos que podemos usar si estamos
trabajando con jules y moles así que
podemos usar el primer valor para la
constante de los gases ideales 8.314
goerges por mol kelvin
pero en realidad no necesitamos hacer el
cálculo porque solo tenemos que
comprobar si k es menor a 1 y miren qué
pasa si elevamos a a un exponente
negativo porque este es un exponente
negativo miren esto es positivo
positivo sabemos que son 298 kelvin y
positivo así que el exponente será
negativo todo esto es negativo
todo esto es negativo por lo tanto
podemos decir que acá es igual a e
elevado a un número negativo
número negativo
y eso es menor a 1 porque recuerden que
si el exponente es 0
a la 0 es igual a 1 pero el elevado a
cualquier número positivo será mayor a 1
y el elevado a cualquier número negativo
es menor a 1 entonces esto será menor a
1 y eso comprueba la afirmación del
estudiante pero si quieren ir un poco
más lejos podemos calcular lo que es
igual a ha elevado a menos 7 1950
jules por moore entre r que ya habíamos
dicho que podíamos usar el valor de
8.314 goerges por mol kelvin entonces
8.314 jules por mol kelvin por 298
kelvin así los que elvin se cancelan y
georges por mol entre yours por moon
también se cancela
porque no vamos a calcular esto solo
porque se siente bien y observen que
obtendremos un resultado que será
dimensional lo cual está bien porque la
constante de equilibrio esa dimensión
entonces vamos a ver esto es divertido
primero multipliquemos esto tenemos
8.314 por 298 que es igual a eso y ahora
necesitamos dividir usar el recíproco de
eso y vamos a multiplicarlo por 7.950 y
ahora vamos a elevar el ala menos eso
que obtuvimos esto es aproximadamente
igual a cero punto cero 404 entonces
esto es aproximadamente igual a cero
punto cero quiera yo soy me olvido
0.0 404 entonces 0.0 404 y la regla para
las cifras significativas puede ser un
poco confusa cuando trabajamos con
exponentes como este pero bueno en
realidad no nos pidieron calcular el
valor exacto espero que al menos esto
les sirva para confirmar que la
constante de equilibrio sin lugar a
dudas es menor a 1